حتى في هذه الأوقات التي يسود فيها الوباء ،
فإن أشهر مخابز لشبونة يقع اللوم عليها
لا تزال تنتج كعكات الكريمة ، لكن المالك
ميغيل كوريا يقول إن عمله قد
تضرر بشدة بسبب قلة السياح
ولا يعتقد أن ذلك سيتغير قريبًا.
بالطبع ولكن أه نحن
نعلم أيضًا أن هذا العام سيكون
عامًا بطيئًا للغاية حتى مع فتح الحدود حتى مع
قيام العديد من
الدول الأوروبية برفع تحذيرات السفر ،
لا يمكن رؤية سوى عدد قليل من السياح في
مدينة لشبونة القديمة التاريخية في ثلاث
مناطق  ليس خطيرًا جدًا فقط
في المساحات الصغيرة هنا في الغرف أو
شيء من هذا القبيل ، ولذا فنحن لسنا خائفين
من ذلك بين الدول الأوروبية ،
تعد البرتغال واحدة من أكثر الدول اعتمادًا على
السياحة ، حيث تطلق الدولة الآن
حملة لاستعادة المسافرين مرة أخرى.
رئيس الوزراء ، كما
كشف النقاب عن البرنامج ، ما هي
استراتيجية البرتغال لمحاولة
إعادة السياحة إلى هذا البلد بطريقة آمنة ،
أنشأنا بروتوكولات بين
السلطات الصحية في جميع أنحاء العالم.
الفنادق لإنشاء بحر خاص نظيف وآمن لإعطاء الجميع ضمانات بأنه يمكنهم القدوم وأنهم سيكونون بأمان ، يُنظر إلى البرتغال على أنها تعاملت بنجاح مع الوباء حتى الآن بعد أن أغلقت مبكرًا عدد القتلى Cova 19 هنا لا يزال منخفضًا ومكافحة فيروس كورونا تظل الإجراءات معروضة بشكل بارز مثل فحوصات درجة الحرارة في المطارات لجميع الوافدين ، يقول رئيس الوزراء إنه يعتقد أن البرتغال تتبع السجل سيساعد البلاد على التغلب على الدول الأخرى في السعي لجذب السياح المرهقين من السرعات التي ذكرناها بالدول التي اختبرت أكثر من البلدان التي تعرف بشكل أفضل الانتشار الحقيقي للفيروس حيث الأرقام هي الأكثر أمانًا وحيث يمكن للناس أن يأتوا بثقة ستكون أحد العوامل المختلفة في لحظة اختيار المكان الذي يذهبون إليه في العطلات هناك أعتقد أن البرتغال وجهة جيدة تضرر الاقتصاد البرتغالي بشدة من جائحة فيروس كورونا الآن البلد الذي يكافح من أجل العودة ما  الملك يعيد
إحياء قطاع السياحة فيه أولوية وطنية
عليا فريد بليتجن سي إن إن لشبونة
البرتغال